gas prices continuing to soar across the
nation many taking desperate measures by
stealing gas from cars it's a problem
starting to pop up here in the valley
victoria saha spoke to one woman who
woke up to find out the gasoline in all
of her work vehicles were emptied out
overnight
it's actually not taking these gas
thieves much to be creative they're
either taking a hose and sneaking it
down your gas tank or
going under and drilling a hole in your
gas tank to drain out your gas stacy
houston woke up to all five of her work
cars showing they were on empty we had a
call we came in to go and then when one
didn't work they jumped in the other and
then the other one and then they started
checking all the the
gauges and they were like oh my god all
our gas she realized this week she was
the latest target for gas thieves
they opened her gas tank door and
siphoned out her diesel fuel from her
pickup trucks and they're huge one of
them is a 14 foot box truck so that's
like 200 worth of gas houston is the
owner of bio clean team her livelihood
depends on responding to clean up calls
any time of the day or night for
homicides or suicides i understand
everybody's hurting but we're all in the
same position you know we're all paying
the same for gas and unfortunately some
of us are running emergency vehicles and
we need our fuel over at universal motor
cars owner victor batnari says he's
gotten a few calls for people who have
had damage done to their gas tanks
thanks to gas thieves this could be like
two three thousand dollars easy in some
of the cars he had a replacement gas
tank for a customer who had their tank
drilled out they have to have such a
flexible pipe that will go to 90 degrees
angle to be able to take fuel out of
this car he says bigger cars are easier
targets because of the straight fuel
pipe there are some things you can do so
you aren't the next target for a gas
thief like park in your garage or buying
one of these gas cap locks victoria saha
live local now